the latest data from our Cobra
coronavirus data file shows that as of
today there have now been 1 million five
hundred and thirty four thousand five
hundred and thirty three tests for
coronavirus across the UK that includes
eighty-six thousand five hundred and
eighty-three tests carried out yesterday
two hundred and six thousand seven
hundred and fifteen people have tested
positive that's an increase of five
thousand six hundred and fourteen cases
since yesterday are those who tested
positive very sadly thirty thousand six
hundred and fifteen people have now died
and my deepest condolences go out to
anyone who's lost a loved one
throughout this pandemic three weeks ago
before the easter bank holiday weekend i
sat out five tests for the UK to move on
to the next phase in this pandemic then
just as now they were calls to ease up
on the restrictions but as the science
made clear we couldn't responsibly do
that in fact the advice from the group
of scientific experts sage who advised
the government made it very clear that
there weren't any changes at all that we
could confidently take without risking a
second peak in this virus that's why we
asked the public to keep going we
weren't done yet we said stick to the
plan and the British public kept going
people stuck to the rules that meant
working from home it meant worries about
money it meant adjusting to home
schooling time apart from family and
friends and just not doing many of the
things that we all enjoy in life at the
same time there's been a lot of people
who despite their own personal
sacrifices have gone the extra mile they
volunteered to support the elderly and
the vulnerable in their community who
have been shielded themselves away from
the virus and each Thursday of course we
now come together to applaud NHS staff
and the carers the people who just kept
going to keep our country going and
because of that monumental effort we've
now past the peak of the virus the NHS
hasn't been overwhelmed we haven't seen
hospital wards overwhelmed with patients
people left without hospital beds people
left with out the
laterz that can mean the difference
between life and death now I know the
tragic death toll in this country and
around the world has been sobering for
all of us and they have been real
challenges in this country with PPE with
care homes but in this first stage of
the fight against kovat 19 through this
national team effort we've prevented the
number of deaths rising to even higher
levels and we've ensured critically that
the NHS had the capacity to cope today
cabinet was updated on sages advice on
the progress that we've made today and
as a result of the social distancing
measures that we put in place the are
level which signifies the rate of
infection is now between nor point five
and not point nine the overall number of
new cases has been steadily falling and
the rate of deaths is also steadily
steadily falling now just to be clear
about what all of this means in practice
the virus is not beaten yet it remains
deadly and infectious and we are working
very hard right across government and
with local government to bring it down
in areas of concern
like in care homes and I'm confident we
can do it and we will do it but because
we held firm three weeks ago we are now
in a position to start think about the
next phase in this pandemic so this
weekend the Prime Minister will set out
the next steps which we can responsibly
take over the following weeks guided by
the scientific advice and mindful as
we've said right from there the word go
off taking the right decisions at the
right time now we can start setting out
how we will live and work whilst
maintaining the necessary social
distancing rules we can also be clear
about those mess measures which are
still necessary to prevent a second peak
the Prime Minister has been directing
ministers and our teams of officials
right across government to carefully
develop a roadmap for the next phase it
contains appropriate measures to be
taken at appropriate milestones subject
to very clear conditions and there will
be detailed guidance to help inform
advise and reassure
the public businesses and other
organizations to get this right we have
set milestones some changes can
confidently be introduced more quickly
than others some of those other ones
will take longer to introduce and it's
important to say this at each point
along the way when we take these
decisions they'll be based on the five
tests and the scientific advice that we
receive and as I set out in the fifth of
our five tests when I spoke here at this
lectern on the 16th of April the point
that we at the point at which we make
even the smallest of changes to the
current guidance will be a point of
maximum risk if people abandon the
social distancing if we forget the
sacrifices that were made to get us
through the peak to get us to this point
the virus will grow again at an
exponential rate that would lead to a
second peak which would threaten the NHS
it would trigger another lockdown which
would prolong the economic pain and
we're determined to keep it temporary to
keep it as short as possible so we kept
the current measures in place for this
long precisely so that we can bounce
back with vigor and energy as soon as
possible as soon as it is responsible to
start looking at the second phase and
because of that our next steps will be
sure-footed and sustainable any changes
that we make will be carefully monitored
if people don't follow the rules or if
we see that the are level goes back up
we will tighten the restrictions again
and we will always retain the option to
do so that way we can safeguard public
health and we can also safeguard the
economy in a sustainable way
so having prepared carefully based on
the updated advice from Sage this
weekend the prime minister will set out
the roadmap for the next phase along
with the conditions for reaching each
milestone mark each milestone that way
we can provide the country with a better
understanding of what lies ahead we can
offer reassurance that we will adjust
the restrictions to the minimum
necessary to prevent a second spike in
the virus and we can give people the
confidence that we're doing it in a way
that will protect life and preserve our
way of life